foreign
you're gathered here
with the three hosts
today
my voice
my guest songs
what are we talking about
means boy in French by the way
I think me and Romney know that bro we
grew up here oh okay I didn't know that
oh come on Romeo how are you going to
hated French class so much man I took it
to a grade nine oh yeah that's like the
minimum requirement to like you know do
it
yeah after that I'm just like yeah you
and like 90 of the students yeah bro
doing myself man yeah but anyways what
are we talking about
rummy
uh today we're going to talk about the
perception of a man and more
specifically how a man should be
perceived and that boils down to his
character his mentality how he acts how
he walks how he talks you know and all
that goes deeper to his character how he
thinks what he believes his focus is in
life and so on and so forth uh so how
this started is we we watched a video
yeah a reaction he made to uh your idea
of you know being a good man versus
being good at being a man and he told
this story
of
um yeah first he didn't put it as a
story he just said like imagine you're
in the situation where you know you're
at a gas station or a petrol station for
the UK people right I flipped it on him
and uh you put your gas you fill up you
go to pay inside and then um you know
you pay you come back on your wife says
like this man has disrespected me he
just said this and that and then you
know get the details on and so forth and
then after that you find the man in the
petrol station you grab him buy his Nike
drag them outside and he's like begging
on his knees and you're like you know uh
did you say this what did you say why
don't you repeat it right now in front
of me and all this stuff and then he
goes on to say that this is the
situation that he was in in his life and
that's exactly what he did
and a few other details I took the guy's
phone and that stuff but not that's
really important right now and uh what
we kind of discussed afterwards you and
me was the honor that a man should have
the firmness a man should have and how a
man should be perceived because he
didn't really do anything that's what
one of the highlights of the videos of
the video he made that he's talking
about he didn't really do anything he
just grabbed the guy and brought him
outside but it was that kind of
the the way the guy perceived him that
scared him more than anything he didn't
throw a punch he didn't break his phone
he didn't do any of this stuff he just
grabbed him very firm brought him
outside and he's like you want to repeat
that what did you say the guy's mom came
and intervened did you watch the video
oh my God yeah of course it's almost
like the fear of the fear is worse than
the fear itself yeah so he might either
use no excessive force you know no
violence no nothing so you couldn't get
him legally it was just positioning
himself in a way where the guy regretted
saying anything to his wife yeah yeah so
and and that brought us to talk about
how and I'll let you talk about what we
spoke about because you phrased it
really really nicely masha'allah so I'm
gonna mention a few things just to set
up I'll pass it on to you but we spoke
about a man and how he should be
perceived his energy his Vibe and how he
should act in accordance to that so why
don't you talk a little bit about that
to tell them what you're telling me
first off I'm ready bro you're probably
gonna be watching this so
um love you for the sake of Allah man
it's been a long time since we talked uh
uh but yeah it's Maddie had mentioned
the um
like is the energy the transference of
energy I can infect the person right
like if someone's has a certain Vibe
like you feel that right off the rip
yeah and what I had mentioned is like
I even made a video for my channel
because I was inspired by like uh
Mandy's video and just like I was you
know what I should share this but uh one
of the things is
when someone comes up to you like let's
say you're you're in a confrontation
with someone
right and like I don't know what y'all
are talking about but like it's you can
tell it's getting a little bit heated
let's say this person is like it's just
kind of quiet they're not saying much
but like bro like you're looking into
the eyes and you can just feel something
off like something's very off-putting
about them yeah they're infecting you
with the energy at that moment in time
what is the energy the energy is that of
someone who's literally willing to lose
everything like he's putting everything
on the table and like you know what if
his time comes like right there and then
like if he's gonna if his if he's gonna
be I'm not gonna say finish bro but if
it's gonna be like the end of his time
right there
like he's willing to accept that and
like when when you're at that staple
like the energy that you transmute the
energy that you give off bro
people know this bro people can feel
that you could be walking you could not
say anything you could be like
in a grocery store looking across the
grocery store lock on the lock eyes onto
someone who has this energy and
immediately you'll feel that and like
you'll actually feel a part of you want
to look away like you won't want to keep
looking at them in the eyes yeah yeah
and this isn't the person that's walking
with their chest puffed out yeah
shoulders back and they're literally
like strutting their songs like walking
yeah like they're in the military or
something like one two one two it's not
like that this is just a simple person
walking
like they mean business in a way yeah
they're just walking and you just know
they mean business yeah yeah but it's
like that time I told you that I was in
Walmart
and um there was just like like thug
like hood dude yeah I told you the story
yeah yeah I don't I didn't tell you
though so I was in Walmart and at the
time this is like the period in my life
where I was like really implementing
like just eye contact and getting over
like all this uh stuff that I had been
taught at growing up and I remember I
was in Walmart and this like this dude
and he was like a hood dude like real
Hood like you could tell probably had a
stripe on him and he's walking with this
girl but like the way that he's walking
like oh but like anyone could just tell
like yo this dude will probably shoot
you on the spot like this man looks like
he just he has something loose in his
head
and bro like I remember looking at this
guy and like I straight up just looked
at him in the eyes
and just like you know he just like
nodded like this like just showing like
yo like I see you there acknowledge you
you're here you know I'm here too bro
like no one else looked at this guy
everyone just kept their head down like
this and like they were passed by him
and they would just be like looking down
at the ground like this and like the
fact that I looked at him like
I don't know I think he was shocked that
I even like held eye contact he actually
looked away from my eye contact and
that's not me boasting my anything
that's just me saying like people
acknowledge this people can see that
energy
you know so it's it's very important
is very important yeah
[Music]
I had no idea what happened bro yeah it
was um it was back in the jacket in the
days
remember the time like when I was like
like my ego was coming out big time
like on the YouTube we're talking I was
um
we're actually just doing the sessions
together
like bro I was
yeah it was it was around the time when
you made the how to increase your
masculine energy yeah guys if you
remember that that angel that's like
that's like my favorite on home bro till
this day yeah Nella bless you bro you
come a long way but bro that that level
that you had is it's what's needed bro
for all these men yeah I watched
Maddie's video response to us and uh I
had this inner thought I was like oh
maybe he's like a lot of people might
perceive him as harsh a lot of people
might just be like bro why is he calling
men you know horses if he can't fight or
if they can't but I was like bro that's
necessary in today's society because
it's how we got to this population of
World season in the first place bro no
one telling them what needs to be said
you know what I mean so it's kind of
like the truth hurts and those lies here
bro for real man and something that I
want to like get across that I think all
y'all would agree on are both all the
y'all that are watching as well is um
you have to figure out where you're at
like
you know how we were talking about this
how like oh you had mentioned oh I'm
like I'm more of a nicer person but it's
like
and I need to be hard and I'm hard and
then I'm like more of a harder person
but when I need to be solved I'm solved
and I think it's very important that you
figure out like which one of these you
lean towards yeah so that way you can
work on the one that you are not
naturally you know inclined to do yeah
see like for me like I grew up in a way
where
um I was just kind of forced to be in
this this odd State I was forced yeah no
it's not even the right one bro
literally it sounds weird to say it
sounds susable like I was forced to be
hard through my upbringing and like that
that kind of was a downfall because I
had to learn okay I need to learn when
to be soft yeah I need to learn when to
soft and when to be loving and
um
yeah this is why I think it's very
important but this is just beyond the
point I just want to throw this thing
yeah just just to bring it all full
circle for men it's it's so much easier
to be perceived as an extreme and to
fall into the extreme or
you know the Other Extreme instead of
being in the middle because we it's so
easy to become one extreme most people
are in one extreme so if you go to this
extreme and go to this extreme you're
gonna have a huge group of community
belongingness all that type of stuff
whether it be politically whether it be
in terms of like other views you know
but rarely do I see people that truly
try to like be in the middle and I feel
like a big reason why people can't do it
is because there's not many people in
the middle yeah so it's not favorable
it's not popular you know what I mean
yeah that's very true yeah we don't have
a lot of good Role Models unfortunately
yeah um well I wanted to also say too if
you had a point go on bro no just just
quickly I wanted to add that a lot of
people I think most people fall into the
nicer side especially if you like you
know in this part of Canada everyone's
like you know
is nice please thank you so so polite
and it's not a bad thing right you can
be you know a tough guy and be polite I
don't think you can most people are just
nice right but I think at the same time
it's easier to be harder and then become
nice than it is to be nice and become
hard because a lot of the time it just
comes off as like this arrogance kind of
like you know they get angry and like
puff their chest out and they're like
they're acting hard and they get slapped
and they run away unfortunately bro just
look at Netflix and Hollywood and the
way they portray men too it's either you
have an absolute idiot who's hard and
you know tough and just rips people
apart in the street you know but there's
no brain there he ends up making a
mistake and led by some woman that
basically tldr men can't make decisions
do you do that or it's gonna be such a
proper guy you know like in terms of
like maybe he's moral maybe he's a nice
guy maybe he's caring you know but he's
weak he gets picked on he's like like a
[ __ ] bro like a simp you know there's no
accurate portrayal in the media I don't
know if you guys have noticed of real
men just a normal man that's balanced
it's always either or so when men see
this bro I don't know if you you know we
have mirror neurons in our brain as as
kids you know in our formative stages as
as Youth and when we watch TV shows or
anime monkeys and we like to feel
empathy towards certain things that we
can connect to so if you're watching
let's say an anime and you're like oh I
really feel like Sasuke you know maybe
you might not have had your parents
killed like Sasuke they maybe might not
have been through all the stuff he's
been through but because you see that
you're just like oh you know I'm gonna
have to act like him now and I'm gonna
like go through the same trials and
tribulations as him nah bro you're you
you're Abdul from freaking Seattle bro
why are you trying to be Sasuke you know
what I mean but or you see something in
let's say another character and it's the
other way and what happens is if you try
to mimic these characters subconsciously
you're falling into the extreme that
they're falling into where in reality
they're not correct they're not correct
we should be in the middle path and the
prophet saws was the perfect example of
balance and fine-tuning and being in the
middle path for mankind so if we already
have that why result
yeah it's like you have the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam you have the
companions
right so it's like these are the perfect
examples and man like I think I think
these are characters and like animes TV
shows movies and stuff like that I think
it's dangerous because it's fake yeah
you know and like like you said you know
we've watched this and it's like a part
of us wants to mirror that because we
see something in them they're like oh
like I could see myself in this
character
you know like
how how silly is that like you're
watching a show
like it's it's like an animated show and
you're like oh yeah you remember as a
kid watching like Spider-Man or like
super movies and you're just like at the
end of it you just feel like the things
that they've been through yeah and a
part of you just like like it could be a
few hours even after the movie but
you're just like in an altered state of
consciousness it's not really your
identity exactly and like people always
wonder like oh like it's okay like you
know but it's bro is it really though
because like
you don't even know your own identity
yeah so you resort to being like a
sponge Ramen was talking about this
truth the other day bro yeah um we were
watching something I think it was Better
Call Saul and and it was just these two
couples just arguing bro and just this
woman just was just being a complete
[ __ ] to this man and and this man was
just acting like a bigger one and he was
just fighting and they were arguing and
the Romney said something peculiar that
I want to you know point out he
mentioned that there's women and men
that watch this garbage and then they
carry that home and and have a frame as
if that's how they're supposed to
communicate with their spouse in an
Islamic marriage who who said this is
the norm you know
can you watch stuff and you know draw a
line This is Where I you know I don't
want to like take this home yes but how
many people know how to do the
difference yeah it makes you delusional
to
also
uh well you just you started to take on
certain things like like let's say you
just watched Game of Thrones
and you're on like the first season or
something like that and you see caldrogo
don't spoil anything Bro you've never
seen it I've never seen I'm gonna win I
mean I'm kind of ruining already for you
no I don't know right now man I already
started
I will leave and you can finish this is
Haram
Haram it is there's nudity profanity
how dare you
go uh but I just want to say like if
they get to that point and they see this
character and they start thinking like
ah like
yeah like that's that's that's what I
would be if I was you know in this at
first it starts like innocent like yeah
like if if I was a part of this like
that's that's who I would be you know
like that's that's my character and then
like later on like it just starts like
seeping into their subconscious into
their unconscious and then they start to
portray these things how do I know this
because I did it um like Carl Drogo was
like one of these like dudes where I was
like looking part of me he was like
looking up to and emulating and then
like a friend of mine had said something
because I was like it's so stupid
actually because I I was gonna make a an
Instagram I was like yeah I'm gonna name
myself I remember that that's what
that's when I met you yeah and he's like
bro why I was like yeah because Kyle
Drogo like and I'm like did you know
that his Instagram background was
actually called bro and like my friend
was like bro but
your your own head
and caldro was like a made-up character
I was like well when he said that I put
my head back I was like
were you ready to like put that rubber
ball out here and everything bro yeah
and everything like on my chest that we
really ruining for him listen dude they
are going no I wouldn't say that like
him saying that after a while it started
reflecting on it I'm like
yeah like this this is actually
uh Jason Momoa this is an actor like
playing a character yeah it's playing a
character it's not real like it's not
real like sure some of the the traits
like you can embody this but it's like
the character in and of itself like that
is not real what is real
is you like who you are and like how you
can embody these things and then it goes
back to like the role models that we
have in Islam see back then bro you were
you were not Muslim most of most of my
memories with with you were pretty Islam
not to say that we had some job memories
that's what I'm saying at all it's just
time wise and I remember one of the
things you would always say is what is
real is you and this experience
because he was into like that spiritual
audience though martial Amela bless you
but one thing I want to say is there's
that YouTuber we were talking about a
few days ago you know the one I'm
talking about that red pill YouTuber
right and how you know he still makes
videos you know we're not gonna name any
names though but you know he had the
little music in the back and it was like
sad videos oh yeah yeah and like he has
a decent phone now you know and we were
talking about him and it's it's this
YouTuber
who is African-American right
grew up
in a place that was hard right women
were trifling women were creeping they
were doing XYZ
and because of this instead of really
facing his own biases I'm not trying to
defend the women right because but I'm
just trying to make a point instead of
doing that and like understanding what
dessert but he would literally make
videos saying generalizing like this is
how all women are and this is all this
and a lot of red pill YouTubers do this
right but it's like bro there's so many
Muslims I know that are not like that
they're so proper like
it's it's so foolish though and like
people are following these people as if
they're prophets stuck for Allah and
like they're they're giving sacred
knowledge and paying it forward you know
and we really don't have Role Models so
I really do want to get to this point
for a lot of men that don't have an
identity
regardless of us being Muslim and we
should right yeah what do we do bro
where are we even going with this
conversation well I mean
first I kind of want to comment just one
little point you said that the character
isn't real right right in the shows not
only is the character not real the
interactions aren't real if you try
saying well he's like I'm not saying him
but if you take a character you say what
he said to his wife to your wife you're
not going to get the same damn reaction
all right
it's not it doesn't work like that and
about what you're saying what are we
what are we getting towards yes you
asked a question I wanted to answer
towards the end of what yeah like what
do we do with this identity crisis yeah
so everyone's gonna have their own
identity right and their own identity
might be picked from here and there
growing up and who they are that stuff
that you're stuck with so long as it's
you know who you are that's fine that's
okay who you are is who you are what you
like what you enjoy what you don't like
you can't really change some of these
things right some of these things like
what foods you like even you can't
change that so we're not talking about
these things we're talking about the
characteristics that you actually can
change good habits you can develop
mentalities that you can develop right
you have to bring yourself to be a
better person what does that look like
morally physically spiritually literally
what does that look like to be a better
person look at the profits all of a
sudden look at how he was he was a kind
person you know as far as I know people
wouldn't look at him and be like yeah
you know I don't want to go near him and
this is pre-profhehood yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
and uh you know as they got to know him
more and more they loved him more and
more so I said him right but he was
really strong he was tough on the
battlefield the sahaba used to hide
behind him we were listening to Alexa I
talked about that sahaba used to hide
behind him when he was on the
battlefield that's Allah said him but he
was a kind guy right people approach him
and then he's approachable really
imagine behind the view yeah was the
description of the Sabbath
um used yeah like he was a Modest Mouse
but there was a time when I think one of
the top wrestlers of the the air there
at the time came up to him and they're
like let's wrestle
what's the Apostle salmon say do you say
no Habibi please no I'm violent I'm not
violent I'm a peaceful person don't be
like this you know don't wrestle with
your neighbors your brothers what are
you doing okay let's go hey Russell he
took him down
took him down in a second and the guy
got up like man I wasn't ready I've
slipped out let's go again
second time took him down nothing like
nothing a third time again took him down
like nothing like I walked away in a
shame that's our Prophet that is
all right and that's how we should be
that's how we should be as men but it
doesn't mean being fake hard right it
doesn't mean being the other extreme
where you just you found that perfect
balance between being necessary like
being violent Monastery and being
capable and necessary and also you know
just generally being kind not not being
one to transgress you're not the kind of
guy that's that wrestle you know running
up on people being like let's fight but
if it gets to that
call us let's go yeah
um
but just to clarify right because we
have these role models in Islam they're
amazing Role Models but people who are
looking at these as like the role model
and trying to emulate this mirror this
like you're not going to achieve it 100
yeah you know like we are our own person
and all that the role model is going to
do is going to allow us to uh become a
better version of ourselves yeah right
but we will never be the prophet
Muhammad
we will never be Omar
we will never be Khalid yeah bro we will
never be Hamza
like it's it's the facts you know but
like what we can do is be more light
then yes you know what I'm saying and
like bro I've always wanted to talk
about this I'm definitely gonna make a
video on my Channel about this so
Shameless plug but um if y'all think
about like when y'all were kids and like
y'all grew up like who you were like how
your personality came to be what it is
now it's actually just a collection of
like different traits that you picked up
from other people or like TV shows or
whatever it is like as you went on in
life yeah like I think the only thing
that's really us
is um
I guess like the Charisma you know what
I'm talking about like you know when
you're really tired
and like you you say something or do
something where
there's no filter like you know how a
kid has no filter yeah and um it comes
out very innocent very pure like that's
them I think that's what we are like
when we're really tired that's when like
what we really are comes out
I mean that might also kind of boil down
to certain like biological traits you
know what I mean like if someone's more
empathetic like women are actually more
empathetic because certain like blood
flows more to certain parts of the brain
right so it could just be like the size
of certain glands or like it's more your
field right but you know things like
that that
that pushes them to be like that more
and more biological trades but even that
is still who we are because biologically
we are who we are right 100
um there was one thing I was going to
say Bismillah uh yeah so about what you
were saying earlier right like you're
not you have to be uh you know tough and
strong but you're not gonna puff your
chest out that's another side to the
process in them right let's not decide
to this
where they weren't arrogant
the only time process allowed them to
walk with their chest puffed out was if
they I think when they were coming back
from a war
[Music]
when you basically walk in a quick Pace
way where you're like tough you know you
have to bro yeah or or I think it's just
the Sun but we do it because yeah we're
trying to follow that yeah 100 and um
other than that you can't walk around in
your chest chest puffed out like you're
a big man like you know even during it's
not an arrogant way yeah it's in a way
like to embody strength why does
strength have to be seen as something
arrogant today yeah yeah what's wrong
yeah people look at it like oh that's
toxic masculinity you need to be
vulnerable why why why do I need to be
weak and vulnerable why do I need to you
know lay my neck down on the line for
someone who's not gonna lay their neck
down on the line you know and it's it's
it's it's sad that that's kind of where
we've been pushed to and this really
liberal mentality of you know you know
just do what pleases you and makes you
happy and no one wants to fight no one
wants violence but it happens no one
wants to lose a fight no one wants to
lose when there's violence right and we
have to be prepared for that and to be
prepared you have to do things though
you know most people don't find
comfortable you know working out and
training and and you know getting
punched getting hit losing fights once
in a while to get better and and better
people don't like that but it's what we
have to do as men so you have to kind of
move away from this
this liberal soft you know uh I don't
want to say the word but kind of like
pusillanimous mentality
uh poslanimous mentality
um and but again going back to the point
what I was saying you don't want to lead
you don't want it to lead to arrogance
you said you know one extreme in The
Other Extreme The Other Extreme would be
arrogance you don't want to lead to that
you don't want to walk around with your
chest puffed out like Oh I'm a big man
don't mess with me especially if it's
fake especially if it's fake because
that's the most embarrassing thing if
you get you know humiliated like that
and that's punishable by Allah if you
think that you're higher than someone
else or above someone else you're better
than other people right
you may not even be able to smell the
fragrance of Jannah how demeaning is
that to know that about someone you know
perhaps yourself if you're an arrogant
person you don't want to fall to that
extreme as well you want to be someone
who doesn't think they're better than
anyone else but is willing to take
anybody else this the same that's the
statement I said literally before we
started recording you want to be someone
who's not who doesn't think they're
better than anyone else but they're
willing to take anybody else they're
willing to fight anybody else if the
time comes if need be it's it's it's so
many traits that a person has to
specialize in and adopt you know
humility being humble but being firm
being strong being brave being
courageous all when the time comes and
these are things that men have to work
on developing and if they don't work on
it
then they're regressing in life what you
were saying
reminds me of this this thing called
Riya Ria in Islam which is like just
showing off and you know just acting
overly like putting on this orchestrated
version of piety
but you're not really that's not really
you you know what I mean like for
example
easy way to demonstrate this would be if
you tell other people to pray but you're
not really praying you notice someone's
not in proper hijab but you're just out
here not wearing a job you notice
someone's not really growing their beard
but you might be out here relapsing on
nofap every freaking night you know this
is real bro this is what happens and and
the reason a lot of people do this is
because it gives them a false sense of
righteousness and and gives them a sense
of like okay I'm doing something on the
wrong right path in Islam yes we are
supposed to enjoying good and forbid
evil this is from the Quran so even the
Quran is the Hadith rejecters bro they
can't say anything with this literally
from the Quran like you have to enjoy
good and for believer it's an obligation
among us as a number however at the same
time there is an extreme sense of that
where you're kind of being a hypocrite
bro I'm not calling anyone a monastic or
anything like that I'm just saying it's
hypocritical of you to really like not
take a hard look at yourself in the
mirror and you're going out here showing
off to other people you know I don't
know who's the first person to enter
Johanna bro
I told you this I forgot it's a cardio
uh recital of the Quran memorize of the
Quran who only memorized it because his
intention was to appeal the masses and
impress people instead of actually bro I
don't think from what I know right
around me you haven't memorized the
Quran you have remember the Quran I
definitely haven't memorized the Quran
we're all trying to do a part inshallah
may Allah grant us that title that
success not for the people but for us
just benefiting and paying it forward
but we're not that so just imagine like
you've reached that level the first time
I heard this I was just like bro what
that's crazy like I have no hope because
this guy memorized the Quran mashallah
bless him but it's like then I heard the
second part which was he only memorized
it just to like you know please people
and impress people
and it ties back to what Rami always
says about having bad intention but good
action of course memorizing the Quran is
good action but where was your intent
you know where was your intention so it
really does go go to show that at the
end of the day showing off isn't good I
don't know if you guys have anything to
say about that but or any experiences
but I see a lot of this bro see a lot of
this yeah I mean you see it it's
literally the culture bro it's the
capitalistic culture when you have a
capitalistic culture you're going to
have people showing off and you have
like you know everyone's itching to get
the newest model the newest phone the
newest whatever you're gonna have
showing off because when that's the
focus people are competitive they're
going to compete in whatever they're
focus on if they're focusing on having
newer things better things they're going
to compete in that they compete in that
their ego comes out they show it off you
know what color is your Bugatti uh kind
of thing kind of mentality you know oh
you have an iPhone 6 you know you look
at them like you know and stuff with
this person they're broke they're poor
whatever
man maybe you'll be in Hellfire and
they'll be in general and like that
sounds crude but maybe it's true maybe
that would be the thing that puts you in
maybe them struggling with you know
being broke or whatever Allah allows
them to go through will be their ticket
you never know so that's why man it's
really important and it always goes back
to what I what I'd like to talk about
which is perspective perspective is
everything everything and to give a
simple example you know if I come to you
and I'm like oh on Hill pushed an old
lady in the street you know and then we
all look at him how dare you exactly
like oh he's a monster you know he's
evil whatever and uh then you add the
perspective right of a different person
they're like what he pushed her out of
the way of a moving car he's like now
he's a hero a little bit of perspective
changed everything everything and now
you think that well it's not important
in life it is important in life you know
someone someone you you might think
someone is lazy they're tired they're
showing work late maybe they're working
four jobs to take care of their family
you know you don't know but that
perspective changes everything so the
biggest mistaking you make is thinking
you understand the perspective you know
everything you don't and that's why even
as Muslims we're told to assume the best
because when you assume the best in
others even if you have to make up a
scenario where you're like you feel
sorry for them or adding perspective
like maybe this is why they're like that
you start assuming the best in them they
see that they start assuming the best in
themselves it's kind of like a chain
reaction right and there's so many
things this is just little things that
men can do as Leaders you know as
brothers as Fathers as Sons as whatevers
and sisters as well obviously that will
make the lives of those around them
better and they'll be seen as a better
person in the eyes of Allah
really I want to touch on this too that
you just said like the context the
perspective
we have an issue we have a pandemic of
people talking about their marriage
talking about their relationships
talking about their own personal affairs
too much with other people
should be seek and see how yes
is it necessary yes but I'm talking
about people that just gossip you know
there's so many women I know and men too
but there's a lot of women in my family
anything bad happens they're always
running their mouth about their husband
to other people talking about about them
the thing is maybe he's not a bad guy
and maybe you're just feeling some type
of way because let's say he just came
home and he just said salami just went
to sleep he didn't give you any
attention or anything you go complain
and Advantage it's like oh my man's just
a monster you know he doesn't love me
anymore he's probably doing this and and
the thing is the friends the community
they're gonna have this certain image of
your man because of you
and the thing is maybe the next day you
guys might repair your relationship and
be fine but the issue is people still
have this reputation now of the men and
it's never going to change now because
they're only going to see him as the way
you painted him and I think that in the
in and of itself is going to cause more
complications in you know as things go
on in the future
so
Allah has blessed you with the marriage
Allah has blessed you let's say with the
family
you don't need to always talk to
everyone about it bro yeah you know yeah
we literally just watched I mean I know
you were kind of falling asleep but we
literally just watched a uh on this and
he was using his I forget the word but
specific word from the Quran which means
like private conversation private talks
it's like if me and fire I'm like yo
come here bro and we like we like
quietly whisper in the corner we're
looking at on Hill not talking to him
right that's like we don't want near
some that's like the private talks and
he said that although this is
permissible at times like private
consultations you know you go to your
doctor you go to a physician you go to a
therapist or whatever or you're a lawyer
you know they have um what's it called
confidentiality they need that sometimes
but also it's mentioned in the Quran
the type of secret talks like even what
you know what quora H was doing the
leaders of Quran they wanted to kill the
prophet sallam I really thought he was
going to give that example but he never
got to it like gossip and backbiting all
that yeah like they they met and
actually plotted how to get rid of the
process in them and shaytan came
literally he came in the form of a man
which is like a good kind of you know
figuratively speaking and in our case he
comes to us when we're when we're
talking one-on-one bad about each other
he tries to get us to make it worse and
worse is actually the plan of shaytan
Allah says
mentioned as well but he came in the
form of man literally
and every time they spoke like let's you
know do this with him let's ban him
let's do this Lala he was like it's not
gonna work because this it's not gonna
work because of that he's like
you know someone suggested killing him
he's like that's gonna work he was
shaytan literally sitting right there in
the form of man saying kill him
basically you know that's the kind of
private talks now if you go on a private
talk with someone and maybe your
intention initially is like to get in a
Seahawk yeah yeah and then and then it
becomes in no I I hate them they're so
blah blah blah they're sold this you're
just talking bad about them and now it
becomes something Haram now become
something Haram
so many people nowadays private life
is called a private life for a reason
it's not a public life
yeah it's facts
so
the title back because I mean we started
this AP
saying about the how important it is on
your perception uh how people perceive
you as a man
so
what can what can we leave people with
here
what can we give them to where you know
they can't these brothers can actively
do something
I think as men we should reflect we
should take time off I started growing a
little deeper into meditating after oh
no I had a couple talks with me last
week it's really been I don't want to
say life-changing because it's been
short term but transformative
to say the least
and it helps me understand the side of
me the real me that was kind of
Blindsided see in Psychology I think
it's like about 90 of your thoughts are
subconscious so you know how like you
have this identity but you're like my
name is Rami I don't want to expose your
last name
government name guys what are you saying
uh I just love the way it rolls off yeah
it's easy on the time yeah
and then you look at him he's like okay
my name is arami this is my these are my
siblings this is my family I go here I
do this I like to do I like to eat this
this is my identity this is my ego right
yeah all the stuff you know all the
thoughts you have this is 10 actually
because this is your conscious 90 of
your thoughts are subconscious so the
real good stuff and Trauma and all the
bad stuff all that stuff so it only
comes out when you have time and and
you're like you have given your mind the
space and I found that out and it's it's
life-changing anyway but what I'm trying
to say is for men I recommend y'all to
like take that time to give yourself
that space to like explore and get to
know your side yourself do the inner
work and then you have that
self-understanding and self-awareness
then you can take the next step into
being okay I'm too much this maybe I
should like work on this or maybe this
thought comes up with something that
happened to you time ago and you're like
this is why I act this way maybe I
should change this XYZ
but it's not until you do that that you
have that level of understanding
and I feel like most men including
myself until recently I started taking
this seriously by the help of anho
mashallah
we're too caught up in Dunya so we don't
make the time
that's why
Salah is prescribed to us it's not you
make time you know you whenever you can
and you know you just gotta get five
prayers in a day anytime no it's
prescribed in fixed times write the
correct opinion of the scholars if you
miss a prayer deliberately you can't
even make up for it right can you
voluntarily do other nalafeland of
course but you can't like pray later
this is a cultural thing I don't know
where this came from if you forget
obviously that's a different story you
can pray when you remember or if you
were sleeping Etc but if you
deliberately miss it you can't just make
up for it right why are they in fixed
times so it kind of forces you to like
revolve your life around the remembrance
of Allah but with meditation and other
stuff it's kind of like the unsexy
self-improvement thing we're like I'll
just put it off I'll do it to the end of
the day you're tired you're not gonna do
it but I generally believe not in an
active Worship Center you bother or
anything like that right these are these
are not that but if you want to do
something whether it's a habit
self-exploration meditation journaling
anything like that generally have a
routine
so one of the things I would tell men is
have a routine and make it a resourceful
routine not just something where you're
just like kind of just playing video
games or chilling like that
what about you
um I think you covered the bulk of him
Masha Allah the routine you can get into
things like you know working out and
training and and all these things in
your routine that helps so I won't talk
about that too much because we talked
about it in a few episodes what I do
want to say is just a small reminder to
have you know taqwa have to Aqua have
confidence and Trust in Allah and know
that he is watching is
and focus on on having is a honor not
honor as being you know Ahmad or
Abdullah or whoever you are but have you
know
honor and being a Muslim honor and being
a servant of Allah and be a person who
wants to be honorable in the eyes of
Allah who Allah will say that's an
honorable person that's an honorable
slave of mine you know because when you
do that and you focus on that and all
your social interactions Everything Will
Change like if I just focus on that
right now you know I will instantly
humble myself
same thing in any situation you're
talking to your mother your father your
brother your sister your wife your
husband anyone in the world a stranger
on the street a person that's driving
you in an Uber car right
you you have that as your perception or
as your mentality that you know I need
to be an honorable servant of Allah
Everything Will Change one percent and
the last thing I gotta sit up for this
one you gotta know when to make the
switch
you know like when to basically
let the animal out
and it's like there's this narration of
um
it's really low one I really love one
I love it
he had sent a letter to I don't know who
was I forget you but he was basically
saying like um submit to Allah you know
become Muslim and
um you will be safe there'll be no harm
or pay the jizya right as I believe
that's what the tax right and he's like
but if you don't just know that I bring
you men
who want death as much as you want life
think about that they want death
like they're seeking death as much as
these people are seeking to live because
they know that when they die they're
going to their creator they're going to
Allah so
when I say this thing of like being able
to have this energy where you're not
afraid to lose it all it's like dude
like if if you pass if you end I mean
you're only going to the Creator if you
pass at that point in time like it was
already meant to happen this way you
know it was already written so
you have to know when to hit that switch
and if something happens then you got to
be able to take care of the people that
you're with
then you got to be able to to flip that
and
one death as much as they want life
yeah like the last thing I want to say
with that is that uh if you do this nine
times out of ten it won't end up in the
fight or anything like that because when
someone refuses it's very scary
like I'm sorry I've felt it before and
like I've I've de-escalated and like
brought everything back and and just
like
basically like backed off because I
didn't want to mess with that bro like
at that point in time like I was in high
school and I remember getting in front
of people like this and uh it's it's a
scary feeling
so like I like I said in my video that I
made for the YouTube channel like I've
been on both sides of the spectrum and
uh yeah so that's a good and that's a
good ending iPhone bro beauty and brains
bro I love my body bless you you look
good with the red uh
sisters DMS are unfortunately not open
TBD
never never or never oh never open I uh
with that being said I did want to ask
you one thing
we've been getting a lot of DMS same DM
usually different people
I advise now I'm just playing
the DM that we commonly get a lot is
don't you guys ever get tired of just
talking each other you guys pull up to
the same table or the same whatever and
you guys have been just talking like
just forcing conversation for like the
last Force no but that's what they think
right they're like you guys are just
forcing conversation for almost two
years just to make content are you guys
crazy do you really think we'd be doing
this if it was inorganic and they're
just like how do you guys do it like
it's like I can't even like bear to like
speak with my own family sometimes this
much like how are you guys doing this by
the will of Allah by the will of Allah
when Allah puts connection between peace
is there like you don't have to try you
know it's not a chore and like bro
I mean look I'm I love everyone that we
bring on to the podcast but if you look
at the podcast like there are clearly
people who we connect with and where
there's no connection
when there's no connection like it can
be felt when there is a connection that
can also be felt yeah and like for the
most part like with us like bro there's
a connection we don't try and look like
we weren't recording these videos we'd
be talking either way exactly one I just
said record those are new exactly and to
tie it all together before Romney gives
the the Dua at the end
connection just like you just said how
important is it for men today that want
to be a good man
to like have role models and those that
He surrounds himself with to push him to
the next level
they say if if you are in a group of
let's say you know people that are kind
of bums they're making like 10K a year
let's say you're making 20K you're
you're not going to change bro because
you you've mentally convinced yourself
that you're better than the crowd you're
ahead of the Curve but go go hang out
with a bunch of millionaires make them
the five that you I'm not saying cut off
people that are poor of course not
context guys come on now
you go with the millionaires you're
gonna feel uncomfortable bro you're
going to be pushed outside your comfort
zone you we as human beings were
hardwired to get uncomfortable when we
don't feel this belongingness to the
tribe and you have people making
millionaire million dollars a year
you're making 20K you're gonna change
that you want to be better at you know
consistent with your acts of worship
reciting and reading on every single day
praying you're acting you're here with
with freaking people in the street bro
roadmands what you know and it could be
it could go with anything in life you
want to be in shape and you're not
hanging out with people that are doing
sports or MMA or in the gym it's not
going to happen bro so I think one extra
thing to add is a bonus tip for anyone
that made it this far is if you really
want to take yourself to the next level
surround yourself with like-minded
people
and I think me angel and Rami the three
of us
yes we've helped one another out many
times we've benefited one another
alhamdulillah
but we also benefited ourselves a lot
being around one another
and that's something that it doesn't get
talked about a lot but we're just like
y'all we're imperfect we go through our
normal things day to day but we have
each other's backs and people people are
like oh it feels good to like feel like
I'm part of the campfire when I watch
your videos but you guys need friends in
real life too
close trusted people that you can rely
on at times of need and Times of
hardship you know and it kind of sucks
not having that bro I know from personal
experience in the past so make sure you
guys get a network so you're never alone
people that check up on you and and this
is to other people too if you know
someone that's probably not getting
checked up on bro check up on them
someone that's that's just kind of you
know you think he's fine but is he
really you know
and then before you know it
the Unspeakable happens this is common
bro so check up on people in your family
or friends that you know they might not
have anyone you know be that friend you
wish you had bro
and with that being said Allah
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]